[Music]
there's this new video of this guy who I
think is in court for this but he he got
mad and for some reason there's car he's
one of these people that records his own
drives I saw that the flower festival or
whatever yeah he sort of
D construction he drives off he's like
[__] this [__] but you really you're
like yeah
you're just like I've been close to like
pissed off but you just would never do
it you're like yeah I'm not going to but
you're like I can see why he's pissed
off at first but then you're like oh
this dude is crazy and it lasts a while
too it's so long like he let his
intrusive thoughts win go home he let
his intrusive thought win for a second
and then he kept letting I know and then
he really stuck with the bit he did he
stuck with it every mother
[Music]
exit but haven't we all that like
somebody's dad who's just like this I me
he's like barbecuing for you and you're
like you got some real anger under there
don't you bro up on the side Let It
Go the
music it's like this kind of what is
that kind of
music the song really makes sense too oh
he's in a dark place what is that he's
getting Uber
notification dude all these dreams in
the background while this song is going
he's just yeah but the song is like you
think you can get me but I you can't or
something it's like really
matching this like a festival right like
now it's like he's in the he's in the
parade right right it's like off and he
was like I want to use this street this
shouldn't be closed he had the perfect
out if he got pulled over he's like oh
sorry I'm with I'm with this float I'm
the float they just told me to join my
bad he's like sorry I was playing Ang
Angry Dad in the parade well I I thought
I was late that's why I jumped all the
construction wait so what does he do he
eventually just parks at his house go to
the end he pull his driveway and he's
like he actually just gets through the
Festival he invades the cops and parks
at home
right cuz the cops are chasing him but
he got away at first they eventually
find him
he's stressed nothing like a it's also
very sad to watch cuz you're like it's
just really sad for every yeah just
reality in right now yeah yeah you you
can kind of think of he's thinking about
it you can tell he's trying to be like
know I'm still tough you know so what
happened no I think he's thinking like
ah [__] maybe I shouldn't have done that
yeah for sure am I going to get in
trouble for this what um wait was I
feeling myself doing that what ended up
happening to him uh like he's probably
going to jail but how
long let's see there was a car chase
last night in like Orange County or
something who that they had a hel like
the stream from the helicopter on Tik
Tok as a live stream and so my friends
and I were watching this stream of this
guy like cruising down the highway just
sideswiping people like not giving a
[__] and then he parks in this
neighborhood like hops gets out and runs
hops over this person's backyard hops
into somebody else's yard that person is
outside he runs in their house this is
all from a helicopter view so it like
looks like a video game he runs in their
house you don't see what happens he's in
there for a little bit and then he runs
out the front door there's like three
people that come out after him one of
the guys has a
gun he gets he somehow got this person's
car keys from inside the house gets in
the guy's truck the guy shoots inside
the truck the guy takes the truck and
drives it onto the highway and continues
the the car chase in this new car
wow wow and what happened they got him I
turned the stream off I don't know I
don't know eventually no they did get
him eventually apparently it ended
pretty boring but's like well that was
just it you know it said part two but I
went to the guy's profile and I couldn't
find part two yeah 38
counts of what wait is this the person
last night no no no this is
the parade guy so wild that he was
filming three angles of his own crime
dude no because ALS so it's like it
always makes sense it's like it's like
when you're that person that yeah that
like thinks you need to filmed cuz
everybody else is out to get you it's
like yeah cuz you're nuts fing
yourself filming yourself driving
through a parade this dude had a [__]
multicam sitcom of him committing a
felony man you see the [__] guy from
succession drove into that pizza shop so
good wait wait the reason I saw that is
cuz I'm thinking about getting a rivan
truck yeah yeah yeah and then somebody
sends me this thing rivan truck drives
into pizza place and I was like was that
is that about the trunk was it Conrad's
fault uh he stayed on the SC he stayed
on the scene he was not drunk not on
drugs I think it was a legitimate
accident I think it's because that truck
is hard to drive and it's super heavy
and has crazy torque this is what I'm
thinking so people crash apparently what
I was reading on Reddit like apparently
people crash these pretty often I know
you kind of get a read from them where
you're like that looks awesome but
that's a lot of electric power on a big
machine like that yeah I know I think
maybe unfamiliar unfamiliar Rarity with
tech Polie say with tech I mean bro just
Tech in general or wait can you pull up
who that is what is this all these
doohickeys oh this thing's got a iPad on
the yeah oh my God but no one was
injured no one was injured I think oh
thank God God I feel like celebrities do
this pretty
often Drive their cars St listen buddy
your career hasn't started until you've
D into a building Christina Applegate or
something Christina Applegate is the one
that has Ms right no not her wait so are
these just for show like if I do this no
no no no no I that's just me being lazy
oh okay okay I am thinking for my live
show I I should get like one of these
mics if I got this in front of me with
the filter hey you should definitely do
the but with those talk mics isn't the
quality kind of bad probably worse yeah
maybe I'll just have to do maybe I'll
hold it a little far away yeah you see
my hello it'll be cool yeah cuz you you
want to sing in that [__] I'm
almost sing yeah I'm almost sing CD wait
I got to have some good Tik toks liked
somewhere oh bro no I sent some you you
ain't even hit
mine this is this is how gen Z drives
cuz they're used to everything being 2x
right wait I was just trying to fast
forward the
freeway I hate these kids man dude this
sucks man why would you do this I always
see these people driving by and I'm like
shut
up I blame assetto Corso for this why is
he doing this there's this [__]
there's this dude doing this I feel like
it started with this accetto Corsa level
where it mimics like the Japanese like
their main Highway and drive like drift
cars like in between the traffic and
then I think it started with one kid
going I'm going to do this locally and
then here we go that song that's playing
is kind of a Bop though oh yeah that's a
tried and true Bop what is that who is
that um that's um that's a boogie with a
hoodie rest in peace man a boogie a
boogie yeah it remind Boogie didn't die
do you love me a boogie with the hoodie
yes he's he
passed what you didn't know this dude
it's the story story is [__]
tragic what are you talking about a
boogie yeah dude this
dude who am I thinking of you're
thinking
of um I don't know but he's still
alive no this is swerving
by that's swerving that's swerving by a
boogie with a hoodie yeah who am I
thinking
of